finally here's one how to date a white
woman a practical guide for Asian men
that's one page to excuse me
do you like a jam it no thank you
out-of-date a black woman a practical
guide to Asian same things you like
Asian me I don't even like Chinese food
[Applause]
don't stay which in no time
I don't leave what I came from us
all right so Regent men were upset of
course Asian men were upset they have a
right to be upset I mean in America
there's been appropriate about Asian
people not being attractive and [ __ ]
like that and it stems from every time
my back in the days when there's a lot
that was immigration from from Asia
there was a lot of men I was trying to
look for work you know young sexy men
full of muscles and [ __ ] like that run
in the streets of San Francisco and [ __ ]
but now all the women would you know hey
a young boy with a six-pack of a young
boy with a suspect they look good
another thing that happened with all
that would he did a bit did it but a bit
of what they did with black facing you
know they did the same thing with Asian
so they every movie that they came out
with that they were depicting Haitian as
quirky corny and ugly nerdy all of that
Hollywood did that just to protect right
you know don't do we don't want them
make them look too appealing because
they were working construction and they
already look good with all the big
muscles in [ __ ] like that we want to
protect our women because our Bomi key
not goes with the hey geez the
Communists hey hey Jim yeah as if there
are cross between nations in Asia yes
they are
hey hey we both eat rice what's up
people I don't really like to take ages
right you don't like to date them
because you've been spoon-fed by that
wrong again exactly is that propaganda
yo look at old Looney tune cartoons how
[ __ ] racist that was look at it Bugs
Bunny and man that [ __ ] was hella racist
yo there's some gems out there to
demonstrate how to constructing a
delicious a Japanese a club sandwich
slice bread ration card oh please piece
of meat ration card soul then eat them
Oh yum yum a sandwich
after eating you are enjoying a crumb
[Music]
age is always like all that [ __ ]
corny [ __ ] yeah that was nice if you
were if you watched eating that was
racist [ __ ] Asians were always the
bad guy
the Asians were the bad guys the blacks
were [ __ ] everything's black live a
lot like I was always [ __ ] weed sided
and it was part of that propaganda and
you were spoon fed that [ __ ] that's why
you think like that and that's why these
[ __ ] man there's book like that my main
thing is like there is a certain double
standard where we allow ourselves to
make fun of men but also particularly
Asian people yeah if you listen to a lot
of comedy from like the early 90s 80s
like it was a lot of comics too black
comics especially we just made racial
material like that with no point to it
that's right lowbrow below-the-belt
garbage and that's what that isn't it I
mean I get why you guys are upset but I
mean Steve garbage Steve carpets Steve
garbage that came up so nicely garbage
is known for making carbon so you just
gotta kinda accept it's one of those
things just don't get upset with people
who are known for a hot garbage I don't
get mad when Donald Trump makes an
inappropriate Donald Trump I don't make
I don't get mad when Bill Clinton gives
a nice I glance to do because it's what
they all do and Steve Harvey is no
different to me he's very consistent
he's done a lot of material like that so
be mad I get it but don't be surprised
that's all I'm saying so all this to say
we appreciate you Asian folks all right
we love y'all and yeah whatever Steve
Harvey said his wife I Greek but an
explorer for other people Explorer open
up your mind it's not I'm not just
Chinese food not just sushi there's a
lot more I love Asian culture like I eat
sushi [ __ ] and sushi box Oh got it here
that's not what the [ __ ] what's
honorable hey y'all tell us what you
guys think about this video and that's
it for today
leymah [ __ ] alright so that's it for
today's video if you guys like that be
sure to LIKE subscribe Facebook YouTube
we don't put everything on Facebook
because YouTube's our main [ __ ]
follow us on Instagram all that good
stuff we got a patreon page so if you
want don't need a little bit money you
know give us a little thumbs up then we
do a little I definitely went the wrong
direction yeah but that's it so you know
thanks holler a dollar makes me holler